you
the only thing better than one Wonder
Woman is - yes I am the bearer of the
torch and now I'm passing it forward I
just love her very much so and I think
that you such a special woman
yes that's original Wonder Woman Lynda
Carter I'll make you proud posing with
our new Wonder Woman gal gadot at the
film's premiere on Thursday in LA no one
else will defend the world than I must
it's always great to see especially
tonight where she's gonna see the movie
for the first time and my heart goes
like I couldn't wait to meet gal and I
want you know this is Wonder Woman
belongs to you she's there she's here
and I understand that we have become
friends and I am just thrilled to be
here for you prepared to become one of
our she Rose like Lynda Carter I'm there
I'm already there definitely Linda
already thanked me for sharing the
burden in her I've been up to it are you
nervous at all to see it I can't breathe
I'm so excited and I really want I
really want you all to embrace this this
is just another way to look at Wonder
Woman so here we go it is our sacred
duty to defend the world and it's what
I'm going to do
you